the idea of expected frequency really
it's the heart of why we care about
probability and chance at all because if
you understand probability chance then
you can predict how frequently something
will happen which is kind of like a big
freakin deal
the huge like economy that we all rely
upon and all interact with things like
insurance things like yo you know when I
say [ __ ] insurance like your premiums
like a vase you're more like the
mortgages that your houses are that you
live in or flatter you live in sort of
all predicated on or based on how likely
things that happen are to happen in the
future okay so I want you to remember
you can jot this down under the heading
remember
the probability of an event we've looked
at this before it's a fraction right
what goes on the numerator and
denominator fraction I'll give you a
clue it starts with number it's a
caterer number of okay we'll come to
order a little bit later on for now
we're not even worrying about like
getting a whole bunch of things in order
we just like the chance of a single
event no order I think I've heard it so
number of favorable outcomes
yeah very good so once you get one it
sort of unfolds the other it's like
there's some event that you're
interested in some favorable outcome or
event you want to know how many times
can that happen and then how many times
or how many different things are
possible and we call these possible
outcomes the total possible outcomes we
call that the sample space right so the
idea of frequency frequency is how many
times you do an experiment right like
how many times do you flip a coin how
many times do you roll the dice how many
times do you deal out a card how many
times do you repeat this experiment
experiment is the technical word for it
multiplied by your probability okay let
me say that again if you want to know
how frequency something is likely to
happen
I'm going to borrow early on did you
shuffle them up for me thank you no I
don't thank you very much for taking
them up
you've got your deck of cards right and
then you're interested okay well you
know what's the probability say of
dealing out a space now you guys do what
the probability is so the frequency how
many times would you expect to get a
spade if I say dealt out twenty cards
right well I would say as an example
frequency of I'm going to try my hand
again here and it looks paid like okay
frequency spades if I'd dealt out thank
you
if I dealt out we'll make it an easier
number if I Delta twelve cards okay if I
went 12 times I would multiply by the
probability which is how many suits are
there in a deck of cards again there are
four and four equal chance so I'd say 12
times 1/4 so I would expect if I dealt
out 12 cards that I would get how many
12 times 1/4 which is 3 so I would
expect that I would get three spades
okay now keep in mind this is a little
bit different and I'm actually going to
grab it here it is ever so slightly
different to dealing out 12 cards
because think about this right if I
actually deal out can you see that you
could 12 cards I'm just going to pause
there for a second
I'm not done yet right I'm not done yet
but look I've already got three spades
oh that's creepy okay now here's the
thing right when I deal out the more
spades ideal out there's actually less
and less chance for me to continue
dealing out spades right I guess what
are you looking for you know what the
map competition is what period it's on
Thursday we're finalizing the truth this
afternoon is you are you aced your math
teacher right now hmm I could look it up
for you
you're going to get a notice in the next
couple of days it's gonna be in the
Daily News as well so I would just check
they're like we're literally discussing
it in our faculty
afternoon okay let's go they're keen
okay so um let me just come back to my
previous point when I'm dealing out
cards right you guys remember how we've
talked about with replacement or without
replacement before you remember that
okay now if I've dealt out let's just
suppose I've dealt at these three speeds
now write the probability of getting the
next spades not a quarter anymore do you
see why why is it a quarter at the
beginning everything is even nothing has
been touched nothing has been given out
but if I give out a whole bunch of
spades now there are less spades left in
my hand so actually the probability is
less what we really want and I need
y'all to get e cards and I hope they're
shuffled what we really want is for
twelve of us with our own independent
decks of cards now do we actually have
because you guys have won between two
right so do we have can you hold up your
deck of cards for me like one of you in
the pair pull out your deck of cards
just I want to feel many decks around
with one two three four five six seven
eight and you guys don't have you guys
don't have depth of cut you guys have
won between the three of you okay so did
you could I just say I counted to eight
right okay so we know thanks that's good
right we know we can change this fairly
easily right I can work out the
frequency of spades if it's eight cards
instead of twelve by just changing this
into an eight so how many would you
expect if eight times what it should be
it should be 2 right okay
here's what I want you to do eight decks
of cards I want you to go ahead and take
off a card one card diamonds actually
I'm going to I'm going to take a leaf
out of um a keel book and just go
diamonds clubs hearts always yours
Renault Ewing okay you guys can you can
claim that that's fine okay hands up
diamonds how many times we have really
zero diamonds poor diamonds that's sad
okay clubs how many clubs one two three
hot-too space go to clubs for so how
many how many states do I have one
oh there's my one I haven't taken in the
state now there we go hold on the club
as well that is how many times you do
this experiment okay so we just did this
experiment eight times does that make
sense I did it once either once you
don't want it all together we did it
eight times okay does that make sense
now have a look at what we go it's not
what you expected is it right but that's
because this is chance this is it's not
going to happen
two two two two every single time in
fact let's try again shuffle up your
cardigan shuffle card okay shuffle
shuffle shuffle okay some good Chablis
okay excuse me
so we're going to do this experiment
again eight times and let's see what
happens
are you ready can we all do at the same
time let some sweet some sweet shuffling
going on okay ready set go okay I've got
a diamond anyone else got diamonds
two of us who's got a club any clubs one
just the one hot whoa wait I think
that's that's one deck right yep so one
two three so does that mean there's two
people two people have we got two spades
one two like so wait but that that adds
up to nine do we have you already I'm so
confused
I'm just going to leave it as it is it
adds up to a we're doing eight times
okay so you can see what's happening
right
can we add up we've now done this not
eight times but sixteen times so how
many would you expect what is the
expected frequency of any of these being
it we've done X 16 times and the H is 4
right so we've got so far
two six five three okay Shh one last
time shuffle again if you haven't
already so easy to music goes on a
period six okay all right so once you've
shuffled say it again do I know
increased unison tricks haven't I shown
you some tricks yeah okay all right you
ready you ready okay here we go
and my card is the ten of spades tennis
players who else has a spade anyone else
no other Spade just me how hard is it to
draw one card guys so I'm the only got
two spades okay I'll put it here
hot we are taught one two three hot
clubs to wait really so two diamonds
okay
now have a look at that can you guys
have a look at that like my chance right
bambam bet okay so what's the key idea
what's the key idea three things number
one if you want to predict how
frequently something will happen then
you think about its probability
each multiplied by how many times you
try an experiment out eight times 16
times 24 times is how many times is
going
No secondly secondly and this is worth
writing down because I talked about it
but we haven't actually stated it okay
underneath here theoretical probability
see your reticle probability is this
number here a quarter it's like what
happens in perfect circumstances
theoretical probability does not equal
almost always does not equal we call
experimental probability experimental
probability is what we just did we did
an experiment we actually tried it out
and we saw what happened there was one
time by chance because by chance
eventually something happen where our
experimental probability was exactly
equal to our theoretical probability but
that was a coincidence because look it
happened completely differently look
there were no diamonds in this first one
okay so what we predict isn't actually
always what happens in reality but the
longer we do things the closer these are
going to come together the fancy way
words that is these converge the more
and more experiments we do the closer
these two get to each other does that
make sense